hello everyone and thank you for all
your support during the past ten days or
so I will talk a bit more about the
events that occurred over the past week
but we're gonna for those who are
interested I will mention that at the
end of the video so this is a game that
happened last week
Fabiana Carolina versus Alvarez of
Fallujah from the protest league and
it's quite the game they call it the
game of the season the protest League
season so let's check it out and the
what's going on so the time format in
the in the process League games is ten
minutes per per well per player and the
two seconds move increment so without
further ado let's check it out Khurana
opens with E 4 with E 5 by fusion Knight
f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
reuleaux pieces on the board and now
Knight to f6 the Berlin defense we have
d3 Bishop to c5 so all standard stuff
Bishop captures captures and now Knight
B to d2 the night is now coming to c4
from where this night will help this
night ago after the e5 pawn so the show
back to d6 the bishop now already guards
it
we have Knight to c4 now with a double
attack here and Knight to d7 now
defending the d5 pawn twice also and
getting ready to play f6 that the
further guard the pawn also may be a 5
is an idea in some lines so we'll see
yeah and here castles
Bishop to g5 and h4 are known moves in
the position but here Fabi played b3
it's a new move in the position so
already as of move 8 we have a
completely new game now he's preparing
Bishop to b2 now he's going to add a
third attacker to the e5 pawn so Jerusha
just castles with Bishop to b2 and now
rook to e8 now the Brooke also defends
the pawn you will not have the rook on
f8 if you want to maybe execute f5 in
the future but that's probably the
difference in what what Carwin are
prepared for this game with his bishop
with his b3 followed by Bishop to b2
line so let's see what happens with
castles and now b6 preparing to play a5
and Finn not being get to the bishop but
play Bishop to a6
we have g3 and now comes a 5
if a for not allowing a for from black
and the now Bishop to e6
we have Knights to e3 I know then I can
come to five also if c5 is played then
the d5 square will be available to the
knight and the Bishop to c5 by future
now if you just bishop pair is well we
could say almost fully operational
Quinta e - Bobby wants to play King h1
or King G to move the knight and play f4
and then he needs another defender of
the night so so Queen e2 is a nice move
also you are you are connecting your
looks which is always nice so f6
strengthening the pawn on e5 now the
bishop on b2 isn't all that strong but
now these lights were have been somewhat
weakened so nights the h4 also you free
D the this f3 square so you can put it
upon to f4 we have Knights the f8 and
the knight is now coming to e6 from
where you will have nice control over d4
and F for squares and then now King the
h1 you don't want to push a for a while
your king is still on g1 Queen to d7 now
connecting rooks also developing the
Queen and rook eight d1 first rook a to
the eighth by Fallujah also when the
Queen moves you want to have nice
control over the D file and now Knight H
back to g2 and grabbing more control of
the f4 square also if maybe a trade
happens here you can even bring the
knight here but you are basically
preparing f4 now and here comes Knight
the e6 this is what we lose you're
prepared in anticipation of f4 so now
everything is in perfect place there's
no really good way to improve the
position further so it's time to make a
breakthrough with f4 by Fabi and now if
you capture capture then you know could
be anyone's game it's really really well
tough looking position the bishop sort
of comes alive you can bring the ropes
here maybe look you want to be g3 bring
the other look over to g1 with the G
file semi open it could be a bit
problematic for black so instead we have
nights to d4 now attacking the Queen
kind of trying to get rid of the the
dark square bishop as well so Queen to
h5 instead by Fabi
it's a your queen was under attack so h5
is AI is
nice square and the Queen to f7 offering
a trade my future so Fabi obliges Queen
captures we have King captures and f7
also this does improve the position of
the king somewhat F captures an e5 and
you cannot capture because of the rook
on f1 so rook captures on e5
and now rook the detail as the c2 point
is under attack you want to defend it
also in the future you might want to
well bring the I look over to f2 maybe
to create some threats along the F file
maybe some some how you can break
through with the g4 g5 not right away
but maybe in the future so look back the
eh you don't appreciate your room being
here on e5 with the bishop ex x-raying
it like that so looked at rookie te8
and here Fabi played g4 it's it's an
interesting move which which allows
fugitive to go for a really nice idea he
wants that he wants to play g5 he wants
the free the e5 square so you can start
a start push pushing later on and also
since the king is on f7 nicely in front
of the rook g5 does make sense but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find y g4 doesn't really work in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on finding such
a beautiful move with the night and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's night captures and c2 and this
is why GG for was a bit premature now
the problem is if you capture the night
with the rook you get Bishop captures
and d3 now you grab yet another pawn
you're gonna win one of the rooks so
let's say rook c1 characters characters
and now Bishop captures on e3g Knight
captures on e3 and now rook to d3
you're gonna grab another pawn so after
the knight moves you're gonna grab this
pawn attack the bishop put pressure on
the bishop well you're threatening b5
removed the defender of the bishop then
you pick up the bishop so after the
bishop moves you just go route before
you're gonna grab another pawn and then
it's just I mean four points and on the
Queen side completely winning if you go
Knight here to defend it then you lose
this pawn so not gonna work
so Knight captures and c2 in credit
strong rook captures doesn't really it
doesn't really work so [ __ ] plays Knight
captures in situ but now rook captures
and III so you grab yet another pawn and
now the problem with captures is that
after captures again your night and the
Rookery under attack but after you
defend it
Bishop captures on e4 and well the
bishop there now is truly fully
operational you're never gonna move this
night it's a really tough position to be
in
it's I mean it's just much better for
black even though you're down a piece
but this is what Fallujah was going for
so rook F to D one instead and now
Fallujah just continues to grabbing
pawns rook captures and b3 we have
Bishop to b4 offering a trade but future
says no thank you I'm just gonna play my
bishop back to these six I'm gonna keep
the bishop pair and yes you do have
these two nice rooks and the open D file
but with my bishop on d6 you are your
rooks are not very useful and I'm also
having very nice control of the e5
square so chances are you will not be
able to push a five so now Fabi does it
I you could try the defend the a four
point you could try rook to e1 but again
you will not find all that many moves to
play the roofs are pretty much stuck
like this the knight doesn't really have
a good squares if you move this Knight
Bishop b4 will just win material here so
definitely not not a pleasant position
so after Bishop to b6 g if I was played
by Fabi he wants to get this capturing
so ii v can be played but now just c5 by
fuchsia getting rid of the miserable
suffering the b7 square and this
diagonal for his light squared bishop so
bishop the back to a 1 and the now comes
rook captures on e for grabbing yet
another pawn so here fiddle just seven
points of Fabi only three points so it's
it's not even like if you just down a
piece so G captures on f6g captures in
the rook to f2 now putting pressure on
the f6 pawn and thuja doesn't go for
some defensive move to try and keep an
eye on the f6 pawn but rather an active
move rook to e2 he says okay we do trade
rooks here or you grab the f6 pawn but
then I have a super active row Connie to
Bobbie says okay I have to win back
some material rope captures on f6 was
played with check King e7 and now rook
e1 now forcing a rope trade because you
don't want to leave this rope here
especially with the bishop coming to b7
it would just be game over
so rook captures anyone Knight G
captures anyone and Bishop to b7 check
now the bishop pair is becoming more and
more powerful almost Oh a bishop pair
from hell we could say so King to g1 and
the now rook to h3 going after the h2
pawn so rook to F do you have to defend
it but now Bishop the c6 you cannot keep
on defending everything there's nothing
you can do to help out with the defense
of the a4 pawn so rookie to check was
played King d7 and knights that III if I
be trying to activate his pieces as as
as well somehow but it's not that simple
Bishop captures on a4 and now fallujah
has three connected pass bones and also
1 1 C pawn as a spare so Knight g4 you
want to get your Knights as as close as
possible to the black king but well
Bishop to d1 now again forcing more
trades so you do have to go for this
check Knight of 6 check King c6 and rook
the d2 now putting pressure on the
bishop here but Bishop to b3 we have
nice to d3 but now just c4 we have nice
the e5 with check again trying to trying
to get rid of one of the vessels because
the bishop pair is too strong but King
b7 future says nope I'm still keeping my
best repair and King G to getting the
King to Tuesday for square also pushing
the rook back rook to h6 and the now
rook f2 guarding the knight on f6 but
now if you lose just play through just
plan is fairly simple he just needs to
start pushing the pawns if those pawns
well get at least halfway through it's
game over
so b5 with Knight to e4 now putting
pressure on the bishop this way and now
b4 with c3 if c3 is played then this
bishop is completely locked out of the
game so first Bishop the d4 by Fabi
but now c3 so C 2 C 1 is coming Bishop
to e3 by Fabi guarding the sea
square but now rook the e6 putting well
a double attack against the night here
and finally night captures on d6 so the
bishop pair is now no longer existent
but it is no longer even yeah even
important
so rook captures on d6 we have King to
g3 and now Bishop to d5 ring be three
square for the pawn to be pushed
Knights to d3 and now be three so these
pawns are extremely dangerous and
extremely fast Knight c5 check and then
out comes King to c6 the bishop regards
the be three pawn so it's not a problem
rook to f8 Bobby wants to bring the room
behind the passport to guard b1 this way
so B 2 we have rook to b8 but now rook
the g6 with check we have King to f4 and
now before going for this maneuver here
to keep an eye on the b1 square first
rook the g8 going after fabi's rook rook
the b7 the knight nicely guards the rook
and the bishop nicely guards the night
so everything is nicely guarded but
there's a very little fob we can do here
rook f8 check King to g5 and now rook to
f1 finally the rook reaches to help out
the defense of the with the defense of
the b1 square so rook to e7 by Fabi
giving fruga one more move and here if
you just played me one Queen and it was
in this position unmoved 58 in that
Fabiana Caruana resigned the game and a
beautiful beautiful victory by Alireza
future against the number two player in
the world also one of the candidates of
the 2020 candidates tournament and also
the former World Chess Championship
challenger so and not not a bad game
against someone like that by the 16 year
old Fallujah but it's it's such a such a
dominating position even if you bring a
knight into the game it's still a
winning position for black so it's not
that doesn't really matter there are no
tactics after the Queen is brought into
the game rookie 6 checking b5 there are
no more tricks so it's just just a
really a one way game that feelings are
completely dominated so it always it
always
I mean how it always not impresses me
but it always makes me very happy when I
see the bird
in defense being played in such a way
like like when Kramnik played it against
eleven our onion in the candidates in
the candidates tournament two years ago
with that with that brilliancy we
covered it was the the brilliant
immortal game really just you know
something happens and even though the
Berlin is a very positional slow opening
you know you know anything can happen
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Alexander quick Julianne new subs
auditor Scarpia Dhammapada ferrets and
nagarjuna Pongo team for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usually can check to my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Paul Morphy saga and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and now that's it for the game for those
of you who are interested I will not
shed some light on what happened in them
well in the previous week that was
absent some sometimes during last Sunday
like that's some ten ten days ago my
girlfriend's mother had a stroke well
not a stroke it was basically an
aneurysm rupture and it was a it was a
very severe case and happened in Germany
in but Piermont we were in Croatia and
we immediately flew over there they had
to take her over to the to the bigger
better hospital in getting and also in
Germany but after a few days there was
nothing they could do and well in India
and she passed away it was due to severe
case and it was she couldn't recover so
although although you don't know her
through this channel you pretty much
know all of her children all of her
grandchildren you know my my significant
other Jelena you know user of user also
runs a chess channel you know Goran
criminal Dean you only chess you've
played against him on my on my streams
you know her grandsons you know Phillip
and even we've checked out fueled this
game against Casper oh we checked out a
Phillips first victory against the
Grandmaster some maybe maybe two weeks
ago so basically yeah it happened and
it's it's a terrible tragedy and there's
a well there's nothing that can be done
here and it's just it's just the way it
is so there is a
it's well it's it just sucks but what I
wanted to tell you that if you if you
want I will put a link in the
description below to one of yours out of
videos it's a it's a brilliant Queen
sacrifice game between Vasiliev and cook
and the Sergey Karjakin his father
Slavko her husband suggested that game
so if you're interested you can check it
out and also maybe maybe express your
condolences it's not much but in
situations like these only only time can
heal and well maybe just by reading some
of your comments maybe it will at least
take some part of the day you know make
it go faster and I don't know just
thought maybe it would be a nice gesture
I don't often ask anything of you guys
so if you can do that that'd be that'd
be awesome if if not I really I still
appreciate all your support so it will
be the first link you've seen in the
description below so there we have it
that's that's what happened and well
that's the reason for my absence for the
for the past 10 days but yeah once again
I would like to thank all for watching
and yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I will see you
soon a lot like I've already mentioned
so thank you and well see you soon